combined variation is when you're
combining one or more types of variation
for example direct variation inverse
variation or joint variation so just to
quickly refresh direct variation is
going to be in the form y equals a times
X notice that two a is your constant of
variation some books like to use the
letter K or even another variable but
why an X you can see their varying
directly when they're in this form
inverse y equals a divided by X so you
can see that the variable X is in the
denominator when its inverse and then
when it's joint you can see Y varies
jointly with X and Z you can see X and Z
are multiplied together there in the
numerator and you also have that
constant of variation so you're always
going to have that a value in there that
constant so let's go through two
examples I'll show you how to work with
this so the first one it says y varies
jointly with X and the cube of Z and
inversely with M okay let's just stop
right there so see if we can write that
equation we have y varies jointly with
ax and the cube of Z so we have x times
Z cubed then it says in inversely with M
so inversely I'm going to put that
quantity in the denominator now notice
this looks slightly different than what
we talked about here with the joint
variation because it said Y varies
jointly with X and the cube of Z meaning
Z to the third power and then inversely
with M now they give us some information
to help us solve for the a value of the
constant of variation they say when Y is
32 so let's put that in ax is negative 1
Z is 2 and M is 4 so the reason they're
giving us that information is so we can
solve for a we've got 2 cubed is 8 times
negative 1 is negative 8 divided by 4 is
negative 2 so we have 32 equals negative
2a if we divide both sides by negative 2
you can see that our constant of
variation our a value is negative 16 we
can put that back in for a there and now
we've got a more specific equation so y
equals negative 16 x is e cubed all
divided by M so now it says find out
what Y is when X is 3 Z is negative 1
and
four so we're just gonna substitute
these values in now you can see this is
going to be negative 16 times 3 times
negative 1 cubed all divided by 4 so if
we simplify that down let's see we get
negative 1 cubed is negative 1 times
negative 16 is positive 16 times 3 is 48
divided by 4 is 12 so you can see y
equals 12 ok let's do another example
see if you can do this one on your own
it says owl varies inversely with C and
directly with the square root of D okay
let's stop right there for a moment so
how would you write that equation well
let's see we've got al varies inversely
with C so that means that that's going
to go in the denominator the C value we
have our constant of variation a and
directly with the square root of d so
directly that's going to be in the
numerator square root of d ok good now
they give us some information it says if
L is 4 when D is 9 and C is 6
find out what L is when D is 16 and C is
32 okay so what we're gonna do now is
we're gonna substitute we say what if L
is 4 when D is 9 just putting nine in
place of D and C equals 6 let's go ahead
and solve for a now we've got square
root of 9 which is 3 so we have 4 equals
3 a over 6 which 3 divided by 6 is 1/2
so we have 4 times 1/2 a if we multiply
both sides by 2 you can see that a is
coming out to 8 so if we take that 8 and
put it back in for a now we have a more
specific equation that we can work with
so Ali equals 8 times the square root of
D all divided by C but now it says find
out what L is when D is 16 KD is 16 and
C is 32 so square root of 16 is 4 so we
have 8 times 4 divided by 32 8 times 4
is 32 divided by 32 is just equal to 1
so you can see that L is equal to 1 so
basically what you want to do is you
want to work through you know setting up
the general equation solve for your
constant of variation and then the third
step is to substitute in the final value
so you can find out what
outcome is so great job if you want to
see more examples working with direct
variation inverse variation joint
variation check out the videos I have
right there and I'll see you over in
those videos I'll talk to you soon